okay I don't have butter I only have
Earth Balance is that a
tablespoon it looks like a cappuccino
doesn't smell like
Lion
ooh honestly it's
not I don't love that I mean that at the
end there that was like its own pain
actor but yeah the former nurse mom she
knew her literally so pruns are one of
our first line therapies for
constipation because they contain fod
Maps like fructans and sorbitol both of
which can give you the runs and while
this works for a lot of people all on
its own adding a shot of butter in there
basically like Butters up the old bowels
and helps big bulky backed up stools
pass through a little more gently I'm
not sure how I would feel about the
taste either but when you're backed up
pretty much anything's worth a try happy
pooping